hello everybody my name is tiny box Tim
and I'm here to welcome you to the four
horsemen
take it away mark thank you tiny box Tim
you're the best in the world and welcome
back everybody to this lovely custom
story we are wandering into death's
quarter we took a respite in an alcove
where our good friend art her whatever
the hell he's doing here arrested as
well and hopefully we can keep going
into the deep darkness but not that way
I don't know I say hopefully we can go
into the deep darkness I know it's gonna
happen so I'm gonna go through okay
through the book so what was the point
of opening up that other way I mean I
could have walked through there I guess
but they both led to the same outcome
didn't they they did so wait what was
the oh if I need to run through here or
something if I need to come back or if I
need to do something there's got to be
something else here that I'm missing
they wouldn't have sent me all this way
just to do nothing I know it's a pathway
to another area but oh come on there's
got to be something how do you really
need to use my tender boxes more often
alrighty then whatever alright so I'm
gonna go this way now and backtrack a
little bit before I know what I'm doing
has to be something else here no it's a
whole lot of negatory on that one okay
so I'm headed back because I don't have
a key but I can't go back that looks
like a very much one-way street there's
got to be a key around here maybe up in
the alcove where the guy was they left a
key behind maybe among one of these dead
diseased bodies might be a key find a
big rock roll down there oh yes yeah
yeah I love that that's cool that's
awesome alright cool
I've gotten to smash things open in a
long time good to know that physics
still works in hell
all right so now I am really deeper into
death's domain good awaits me
Oh for a second I thought it looked like
I was deep underwater but I wasn't sure
what was going on I was hearing it ooh
not water bubbling bubbling liquid of
goopy goodness so that's gonna help me
do something what I don't know maybe
that's the melted remains of whatever
the hell orb was here that is a big door
and someone's head cut cut clean off by
it
so where do I need to go what do I need
to do what do you want from me game
there's a lot of big oh hi well what the
hell are you doing get out of here
goober uh waiting for something to pop
out of me I need this something to melt
that down
why didn't I keep that glass jar after I
got the orb back I guess I'm going in
here okay this is smart this is a wise
decision huh I don't need this I can see
exactly where I'm going kind of maybe
not pardon I heard some I did okey-dokey
you're good
we are golden okay we made it to the
point where the guy's head was cut off
but his body is nowhere to be found
ran out of oil I am completely out of
oil [ __ ] this is not what I wanted and I
should have been what am I looking at Oh
what am I looking at what am I looking
at
I'm looking at what am I looking at what
am I looking at but at the same time I
don't want to look at it there's
something in here huh
oh good more bodies or just one body
maybe a place to hide if I really needed
it
oh I ran out of oil oh that's bad could
someone please grace me with more oil
thank you I promise I'll be sparing
thank you ah good ice pairing I mean I'm
gonna waste it as soon as it as fast as
possible okay so what is down there just
a whole bunch of bodies god that is
creepy as hell so I don't need to go in
the middle here because obviously there
is nothing standing in there since that
I could pile on I want to know what I
was looking at because for a second I
got the tunnel vision of looking at a
monster I know I did
cannot lie to me I know what I saw come
on give me more
under my going I'm I just going in the
circle
why am I going in a circle this way I
came from
wait what's over here something anything
anything at all I didn't know what I was
passing by when I didn't have any
lantern oil I know at any moment
something is gonna pop out on me just
like that thing standing at you standing
it nevermind goddamn it I was trying to
spook you but it didn't work
it's that thing staring at you oh I'm
not dead I am
oh my god I legitimately just see I was
looking at the camera holy hell
this Hosford what happened oh my god
guys just look down Olson there's a dude
I was trying to get you guys to things
that there was a thing staring in your
closet okay well that was fun can we
differ do that again I'm still kind of
shocked by it
hell it's why was it just standing there
I opened the door and it was like a good
second before I looked back and anything
was happening oh I've ID'd a minute to
recover what the hell
I'm smiling me I'm smiling because that
was like I couldn't have written that
better
I couldn't hadn't made that happen
better and now my voice is going I've
been recording a lot today so my voice
is a little little bit jittery but
goddamn that was a whole lot of
something that was so something all
right
okay so anyway continuing down the death
domain
that's the reason I'm here that's what
I'm doing death death death and all that
death all that lovely deafie death whoo
whoa hello friend this looks interesting
I need to go down there oh I do but let
me just explore this area before I
dedicate myself to climbing down that's
shiny for a reason no anything under the
stairs no what's over here more death oh
not more death what is this oh this is
the Ale room cuz death needs to be drunk
definitely definitely okay I'm all
better now I've recovered from my ordeal
and I'm all better so now I need to find
my way whatever the hell it needs I know
I need to climb down but first I want to
make sure that there's nothing over here
that I could get oh then my a-v like oil
like all of the oil that I need right
now like how I need so much oil there we
go oil thank you thank you for that
friend you're the best
something there's something holding that
closer is it just locked for a reason
better just be like for a reason
all right okay no tiny boxes you're
small but not tiny all right I'm on my
way out then you guys have fun with your
lock things okay
down I go yup okay clunky clunky clunk
this seems rather dangerous and who
would put candles down here I know it's
a good visual clue to tell me where I
need to go but logically speaking is
really precarious hope I sure hope it
doesn't fall good good I'm gonna do
fantastically Hey
okay so so far so good hit okay got it
all right this looks cool god this is
interesting level design I haven't seen
anything like this in any other I don't
see many custom stories taking advantage
of the drawbridges
cuz those seem like something that would
be very very useful in certain
situations but then again you know
yapanese a custom story community is
kind of died down a little bit or not a
little bit but a lot you know I guess
we're all waiting for somin to come out
next year because I know that soma is
probably gonna have plenty of custom
story tools because I'm very eager for
summer because the machine for pigs a
lot of people would agree kind of a
letdown I mean it was great game great
story and all that don't get me wrong it
was great it had his scary moments and I
had some really intriguing things going
on but I don't know it just didn't
scratch though I know what I must do why
what must I do
what do you kill this man why why are
you jumping doing so I offer a sacrifice
a soul to Death himself why are you
jumping that was my only way to access
the oil why are you jumping to
conclusions you don't need to disturb
right out in state that as this art or
his name is Artur this man was found
within the realm and brought here it
seems he was attempting to destroy the
horseman in his possession an orb of
power it has been taken to return to its
quarter he will serve as a sacrifice for
now it is the only way to please death a
sacrifice in his name
well I mean who wrote that message why
why do that thing that you do burn the
imprisoned man is that the necessary way
to kill him our tours my man he left me
with some Doug's I didn't solve his
other puzzle of the herd in the cloth
and the thing but hey you know can't all
be perfect so maybe he doesn't deserve
to die maybe there would be some way
around this horrific fate of which he
has been exposed I don't like it when
they force me to do these things like
kill my only friend here is this what my
daughter Katherine would want there's
got to be something else there's gotta
be something else there has to be please
I'm not giving up I'm gonna run out oil
and then I'm gonna be a big goober oh
wait a minute one of these barrels of
alcohol that one oil not just alcohol
can I get some of that for mine coz I
would like that
now whatever I'll get one hey buddy
we're gonna light up the barbecue don't
worry don't worry it's gonna be well not
fine but it'll be okay for me anyway
maybe you should be happy for me I'm
gonna live a long life now I'm gonna
know in my heart of hearts that you went
into this willingly so uh have fun Oh
sorry
what have I done
I don't know what all can't have time
again well I mean you you you came up
with the idea you can't go back oh no
I'm a horrible monster the right thing
one life is worth sacrifice I didn't
really see any other options but okay if
you want to justify it that way maybe I
could have talked with him mano a mano
apparently not well then now that we got
that taking the life of another to
destroy them but who was he to take a
human life
all these loading screens are talking as
if the story has already come to pass oh
boy oh boy oh boy this is where things
get really fun oh boy all right what
have you got for me come on I'm ready
come here kill me please don't I need to
finish this okay so I did it I got the
orb the only way that I knew how murder
I'm surprised my lovely daughter didn't
come and tell me what I was doing
horribly wrong well come on is there
another way that I'm supposed to go or
do I just need to go back I guess it's
back we go
goodbye pile of bodies I will miss you
why is this one different okay never
mind never mind bye I got no idea I got
no idea I got no idea I think I might be
getting close to the end of the game
though All Things Considered I have four
orbs now don't know what the hell this
was for maybe I could have done
something here maybe I could have done
like a summoning seance for who's it
what's it
maybe there was like a way to light all
these candles if I had save it enough
throughout the entire game I don't know
you guys can let me know if I did the
right or wrong thing in the description
below because maybe I did good maybe I
did bad who knows really only time will
tell
okey-dokey alrighty then I'm out here I
got all my hopes and dreams with me
nothing can come to me now I'm the man
I'm the best ok
so everything is awesome everything is
cool when I'm part of the team
everything is awesome everything is cool
when you're pulling and I don't remember
this part
did I come this way I don't recall where
the hell am I going maybe I need to jump
down there probably not this doesn't
seem right usually there was a return it
was a way to quickly go back to where I
needed to go did I miss that did I miss
that somehow I think I might have missed
it did I do something wrong am I going
the right way
I have a really distinct feeling that
I'm not yeah and all the other ones
there was a return there was an easy
quick way to go back except for the one
where there was a chase sequence
incorporate it into it but that seemed
like a unique scenario I am out of oil
completely in completely ok well there's
the acid what do I need that that seems
important what what was I supposed to do
maybe there was a way if I was able to
get a jar I was gonna be able to I don't
know I don't know something right
something ain't right something ain't
right
I got some not feel right some don't
feel right about this I don't think I'm
well where would I go maybe there was a
way to go get a glass yard Oh make sure
that he wouldn't die by burning off all
of his chains or dissolving over letting
him go it's just really dark in amount
of oil and I don't know if I'm going the
right worry hmm ah I can't go back this
was the wrong way it has led me astray
not notice this before what why are we
dare wonder who or what made this
opening don't just talk about things in
the darkness cuz I can't see [ __ ]
don't talk about this to me huh where am
I going
oh it is dark I do not like this
something is gonna pop out something is
gonna pop out something is gonna pop out
squeak squeak squeak squeak shut up
concentrating okay well then that's good
this is all very good I was wandering
without led to led lead bad lead
okay wait a minute this was down before
huh good that did that thing that that
did I don't know what it did but it did
I think where the hell am I going am I
supposed to go this way
that's a big question I don't know if
I'm sweaty was this Waylon no no who's
the other way yeah yeah yeah I got a
feeling that those I had never mind you
know what never mind
it seems like the only proper way to go
oh go in I shall there we go
all the lovely dead bodies oh hello
where am I going mister turn somewhere I
cannot see a damn thing
what the hell wait a minute
there we go over this way got it got it
got it whoo squish all right okay we
made it out all right we did good we
work on the right way I thought we were
going the wrong way
couldn't see anything cuz of dark but
now I know I'm right my heart of hearts
I have everything I need I can go home
with my head held high and supposedly I
can go into the chamber now ah okay so
it still works oh I didn't break the
game or anything like that
okay you can't help me Alistair nobody
can I'm already dead I figured that you
know this you were with me at my desk
okay you witnessed it and yet you linger
on thinking you're in my company what I
could still save you this isn't over you
I didn't think that not yet I didn't
think that once it will be over
but I what did I do wait a minute no
that doesn't make any sense who the hell
are you why don't I have any oil I
really would like some oil
hello sir that doesn't make any sense I
don't even know who that lady is was she
supposed to be talking to me or
something was there something that I
missed why do I feel like I missed
something I hate it when I feel like I
missed something there's some oil you
know what I'm gonna put it in my lamp
but I'm gonna go without it for a while
longer because I don't want to waste it
that [ __ ] no here we go well what the
hell is gonna why do I hear machinations
and machinery that's a bottomless pit
okay all right okay
good Chuck okay I've crossed the
threshold now okay
ha walking I burnt what the hell ah can
someone open this door hey okay that
ain't happening
oh there you got it okay instead of
finding the right thing I just ended up
throwing my face into the fire which was
one solution
like no more I don't care why must no I
shan't love stand by
and I will
yeah exactly what I said what is that
sound
I think it's music starting to kick up
but then no whoa whoa okay no you ain't
doing that okay this is war nope this
death no you ain't gonna do that
I got loud down to them four days baby
hey famine famine and pestilence oh good
no good bad
well those Alexander's lines from his
thing where he died that thing whoa okay
oh it's back to the beginning of the
game when you looked onto this book with
the flower in it have we done adjusting
that it was over I destroyed yay
the horsemen and all the evil that
followed them
Oh God yay auntie was broken
was done my task was complete yay
veidt's had gone out so
dogs Oh
yeah that's it oh god that was awesome
oh I really really enjoyed that it was a
little bit of confuse in there because
it like Catherine went from being the
daughter to a lady and I wasn't sure
what was going on I was kind of confused
what was going on there but it was like
I think it all meant to be the same
person but I don't know there's just a
little bit of confusion everything way I
need to turn that down either way that
was awesome thank you so much Steve Chan
and Ciaran McGough ah it will in
Zach Mitchell Lucas Matthew Laverne sea
Republic Bridget Grimm
and everybody else so seriously thank
you all so much for watching these I
love when I get to play good custom
story like this cause a lot of fun had
some fantastic scares in it good story
good puzzles I only got lost a few times
in love by my own doing I still feel
like I might have missed a little
something like something I missed I'm
not sure if you guys know what I'm
talking about you can play this game for
yourself links in the description below
or you can tell me about in the comments
below okay I can't say they'll revisit
this game just to try it out but either
way find out for yourself inform the
other guys about it point them to a
video where there is something new if I
did miss something so either way thank
you again everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video alright hello everybody this is
markiplier here
my brand with way of amnesia the Dark
Descent yeah music
yeah I need to change why stop it really
you